earlier this week the New York Times and
Politico revealed the existence of a
secret government program to investigate
UFO sightings it was especially focused
on encounters by members of the military
like this one experienced by a US Navy
pilot off the coast of California the
program began in 2007 and ended five
years later but it's former head Luis
Elizondo is convinced that something
compelling is out there what we are
seeing is something that is not
traditional aircraft it's not a drone
it's not something that we can easily
say oh that's an airplane or that
belongs to this country or that country
in fact my submission is that what we
are looking at is truly by definition
exotic technologies beyond beyond next
generation technologies here with more
about this Pentagon program and the UFO
phenomenon is time science editor
Jeffrey Kluger Jeffrey good morning good
morning
so how surprised were you about this
Pentagon program a surprise program with
a 22 million dollar by 22 million
dollars now I was surprised but not
displeased look for starters 22 million
dollars in a six hundred billion dollar
Pentagon budget in a three point eight
trillion dollar national budget that's a
fact but what they're doing and what
we've been doing as for as long as we've
been looking for these kinds of things
it's simply looking for flying objects
that are where they don't they're not
supposed to be now that could be a
military threat we should be looking at
it but on the one in a million billion
chance that it really is et we kind of
want to know that too is this the
revelation that the conspiracy
conspiracy theorists have been looking
for all along that the government knows
there are actually UFO well it's always
impossible to know what the conspiracy
theories but remember what the
conspiracy theorists would argue in
these cases is that the the government
knows a and that it's covering something
up I don't think this is what they're
looking for
all they are looking for all that's
being said here is that the government
is doing due diligence we need to know
what objects are that haven't been
logged properly and on the off chance
there et all right we should know that
program said it ended in 2012 did it
really well these things have elastic
data and it did not end in 2012 now the
Pentagon still has a lot of people
working for it so even if the program
isn't officially on NASA on the
Pentagon's books anymore
there's still people there who are
keeping an eye open for these things and
are still analyzing the data that comes
in and they should so Jeffrey what's
your take on that Navy footage we saw of
the UFO well I'm going to acknowledge
that it is unusual and it is but
intrudes not a frisbee it's not a
frisbee but intriguing does not mean
extraterrestrial it's worth remembering
we have always seen things that looked
extraordinary and had extraordinary
ordinary explanations John Glenn thought
he saw fireflies outside his spacecraft
and it just turned out to be ice
crystals do we have the technology I
guess the u.s. or any other country
though to do what we saw well it doesn't
appear we do yet but remember the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency the skunk works in which the
Department of Defense comes up with
cutting-edge technology we don't know
what they're doing at any given moment
we don't know what Russia skunkworks
have or what China skunkworks have but
this technology does look like if it is
what it seems to be something that would
be beyond what any of us have yet and we
should know this is not this this
project that the government has was not
the first time they've taken on UFOs no
they haven't they started looking in
1947 when the famed Roswell incidents
happen from 1952 to 1959 69 rather there
was the project Bluebook operation
they're currently other operations going
on now but it's also worth remembering
Project Blue Book had investigated
12,000 different potential sightings
only 702 did not have a direct answer
and that doesn't mean they were et it
just means they couldn't figure out what
they were you come to this from a
scientific background what do you think
UFOs
we are I generally think I do so want to
believe that they're eating because it
would make the world a more interesting
place yeah I just don't think they are
at this point there are way too many
potential world's out there trillions
upon trillions and the idea that these
folks would find their way to our skies
over the United States when we have a
pride and airplane flying it's a long
shot but I love the idea of the bike
going over by the moon now that just at
all
I'm magazines Geoffrey Kruger thank you
thank you so much